I'm just going to merge some NPRs and
stuff today and work on
work on a presentation a little bit.
Make a little bit of material for popper
four.
It's so weird to me to even like be
writing
like so incredibly simple and some such.
It's like people looking for docs cuz
they assume there's complexity, but
there is none.
Likely a few places.
I'm going to like just um
I'm going to send out some
notifications, see who wants a
a short live presentation and Q&A.
Yeah, how long is this? I can probably
do this as like a 15-20 minute talk.
Can we get the end code to fit on one
screen for something, I wonder?
We make a new demo. I'm just trying to
figure out how we invest the time here.
What's like the simplest little
environment I could make that could also
be done multi-agent and stuff
for showing this off.
Presentation just
I guess I could clean this up first.
I think what I really the only thing I'm
really missing on the content side
it's essentially just people keep asking
me for environment tutorials, but like
there just isn't a big API to learn.
I just need a very compelling
demonstration that there isn't
complexity. Like you're looking for
complexity cuz you're used to it, but
there just isn't any.
Let's clean up the rest of the
presentation first.
I also think I do need to darken this
background a little bit
Yeah, yes crit, but like the amount of
required stuff is tiny.
>> I think I shouldn't go crazy with the
effort on this.
I tend to go down rabbit holes of like
how much could I make this better, but
it's really just like
the thing that's ultimately important is
that we get people using the release
and then, you know, we we do the stuff
we need to do for the company and then
we get back to research.
Like that's ultimately what's important.
I think that's the main thing to um
to remember, right?
Uh you can, but it's not when you have
it as the background. Okay.
There we are.
Now you can read it clearly.
Yeah, but snake is like this pixel
looking in.
And it's counter a lot.
No, lines.
Snake is many millions of steps per
second.
The SPS of overall training will depend
on the end count. You can measure the
throughput of your environment
independently.
It looks better without the full trace
on it, but
Oh, wait. That you can't flip it.
So, we'll just do I know we'll do.
Can't flip it.
No, yeah.
One of our collaborators at NYU made it.
I was actually considering porting our
star shader or like figuring out how to
get our star shader to run on the
website.
I might do that at some point. Would be
fun.
uh recept out of the reception to Puffer
4, you know. Puffer 4 took a very long
time.
And it enables us to solve a bunch of
new problems, and people need to know
about it.
Please change resolution.
Sound, right?
This is what we'll do.
Do it like this.
The audience of this is a little
different, Jess. This one is not just
for like getting new contributors. This
one is more aimed at academic labs, um
you know, industry companies that have
internal RL efforts that are thinking
about using us.
That type of a thing.
I do quite a bit already for the general
contributors with all the streams
and all the content I make there.
Um
the company still needs to have a steady
stream of customers.
And we'd like to be taking on some
larger
well, smaller number of larger contracts
now that 4.0 is out.
That way we can like, you know, really
test our stuff against hard problems,
and at the same time
generate a a nice stream of revenue to
keep funding all this stuff.
Classic DOS games? Oh, yeah, for sure.
I wouldn't be surprised that some of the
older games that actually already have
efficient code could just be bound
directly to PufferLib.
Um
at least the ones where they don't hook
in a bunch of depths and like annoying
build stuff.
And then a lot of old games are also
quite easy to just implement standalone.
One of the big ones I'd like to see is
NetHack. The NetHack uh the NetHack
learning environment, they just released
a nice new version of their stuff.
And probably we could just snag their C
We have a GIF of this.
Of a constellation.
>> I would have thought I would have
uploaded this somewhere now.
Wait, why am I like why am I bothering?
I can literally just do this.
Obviously Docker is going to just crash
on us.
Wait, where did the [ __ ] slide just
go?
Oh, here it is.
>> Yeah, so the thing with the cluster
graph Jess or James is um
We didn't get to do enough with that in
the release. There's a lot you can do
with it, but we didn't really have time
to do all that analysis we wanted to
with the release. There was just too
much other stuff to do. So the
visualization is there, but we don't
really have a ton of cool analysis with
it yet.
And I forgot my coffee.
Of course.
>> I forget all sorts of stupid [ __ ] man.
I managed to lose my coffee in the
microwave right before the release and I
was like, all right, I need a vacation.
Literally looked everywhere for my
coffee before realizing I'd left it in
the microwave.
It's actually kind of funny. So, I've
been playing leagues here.
This was kind of my break.
And I ran out of stuff to do. Just on
the side monitor. Like, I literally ran
out of stuff to do.
Because
Eh.
Uh, eh.
There's literally nothing else I can
just do on the side monitor with this.
So, I'm mostly just back to work.
And maybe there is something I can set
up. Hang on.
And then we will I think we'll just see
if we finish this chunk of the to the
presentation slides.
And then we'll work on like a sample
end, which should be useful for
contributors as well.
We'll do like a nice sample end, maybe.
Maybe we'll just clean up the existing
sample code. We'll see.
And then we'll go from there.
I could realistically start thinking
about proper five quite soon.
I think we still have some ends to merge
and fit things to fix, though.
Yeah, I needed to like just put
something that would look cool that I
could build in a very, very short amount
of code. Like, I like something that I
can literally do on a screen.
Maybe like a simple gather and disperse
or something.
We don't really need tons of these super
simple ends that like you insta-solve,
though.
We kind of just need a few of those for
benchmarks.
So, like we kind of want maximum cool in
one screen of code.
Maximum cool in one screen of code is
kind of a fun idea.
Too big, yeah.
I want like one screen of code.
Let's actually just finish the rest of
this talk and then we'll um
we'll do that.
We want to get the language right on
this first.
Upper website you review ends.
Is there a Q?
Uh do you have a PR up?
It's kind of just whoever happens to be
on the live stream when I feel like
reviewing ends.
It's not like the um
grid-based Flappy Bird intro project,
right?
That's like the only thing that would be
too simple. I'll still review it for a
new contributors if it's that. That end
would be too simple to merge.
Yeah, make a PR and like chuck a
screenshot or even better a GIF onto the
the PR so I can kind of see it.
Um raylib has built-in GIF recording
just with control F12.
So, it's super easy to just grab one.
Robin made
Yeah, I can review both of those inish.
Let me get a few more ideas out on um
this on these slides and then I'll
review PRs and then we'll do the other
thing I have planned for today.
positioning of
and then I'll do the Dino PR. I'll I'll
go with once over and then I'll do the
Dino PR.
Um downtime like that isn't super
concerning and Nash.
If they like the giga [ __ ] everything
then sure.
But at the moment like
nah, not really.
Honestly, the best thing that GitHub
does
in my mind the best thing that GitHub
does is actually GitHub pages like
it's honestly just the nicest thing to
have for websites is just pages.
It's kind of funny how they brag about
like all how much AI they're using and
their software which was already dog
[ __ ] keeps getting worse.
Uh another fun one is if you just look
at the number of lines of code in pop
not in popular but popular has been
going down um in pie torch in the last
few years like
ugh.
All right, what do we think of these
slides?
We can preview um
this is a work in progress guys, but
where's the animation?
We have some new animations.
We'll probably stick one of those in.
Okay, cool.
I think these are good.
I could get a quick sauna in and then
I'll look at your stuff and Nash. How's
that?
I'll get a couple ends in.
>> All right, PRs.
Yeah, PRs.
All right, what are we looking at this?
You don't get bonus points because it's
not the puffer fish jumping.
But, uh
Let's see. What do we have?
We've got
Yeah, this num nums param is a useless.
We can get rid of that one param, but
other than that, this is good.
I'd be pretty surprised if this needs
this big of a net, but sure.
Nice puffer net.
Very simple.
381 lines, and is this the only other
file, I'd hope?
Check this height.
This looks good. This looks good.
This looks good.
Huh.
I always think that the enums are a
little bit, um
Yeah, I don't like the space with this
star as well, but, um
This probably Oh, also, you don't even
really
I don't think you need to cast this
anymore, but, um
This should go into
the dot c file
because this is not actually used in the
dot h, but that's not a big deal.
Yeah, so I would say a few very minor
syntax things, but overall, like 9 and
1/2 out of 10 environment.
Oh.
Inish, you still here?
I'll do I'll look at the Dr. Mario one
if you're still here.
Go back to this, I guess, for a little
bit.
Yeah, this was kind of what I was
thinking as like
Any of these like purely competitive
ends, they're annoying to score.
I think I got close to it with um
where's the end?
I'd like it to be something where the
strategy is there's like some sort of
interesting bit to it.
Honestly, a super simple meta grid like
thing might be nice.
This is very close to that. There's too
many agents and such.
I think I can afford to spend a few
hours on this, right?
What's the purpose of this? This was
sort of an experiment in getting like
interesting swarming type behaviors.
It's pretty mesmerizing to look at,
right? It's just like a demo end.
I think I I think we can extend this
concept a little bit more.
And we can like with still multi-agent
but fewer agents.
And we can probably get something
that uh we can use as a demo end with
only like few lines of code.
I don't really want to get distracted in
5 minutes as soon as I start this.
Better than current boids.
Uh this one's not that much code, my
friend.
I mean, if you want to learn some stuff
in the space here,
like Hover's in a way better spot now.
Things are way easier than they've ever
been. Things are way faster than they've
ever been. So, you know, hey, try stuff
again. Pick it back up.
I think what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make something like this with a
smaller number of different colors.
Um
a smaller number of agents, but where
like the stars essentially dim out after
a little bit.
Or they dim out when an agent collects
them
for a little bit.
So, there's hopefully going to be some
more reasonable foraging behaviors.
I'll be right back.
I'm going to go get my vitamins, ask
another coffee.
And then we will start this properly.
I think I can probably I guess this will
be a test of whether I'm actually back
my mental facilities are somewhat back.
Cuz this is something I know that me
with like full focus and stuff, I should
be able to knock out in like 2 hours
without touching AI.
Give me a few minutes.
Multi-factor, some factors.
Yeah, but like
I think it's likely you're just
overcomplicating things, man, and you're
trying to do the full problem at once,
and you're not like you're not
approaching it constructively in a way
that you can like okay, does it learn
this? Does it learn this? Does it learn
these two things together? How do these
interact? Like
I think it's a lot to do with the way
that you're approaching the problem, and
that comes from experience.
Right? But, you also have me here as a
resource to ask me stuff.
So.
Let me get myself uh
music for background, and I will go
through this end.
And then what we'll do is I'll sort of
talk through this while I'm building it.
Hopefully you all can learn some good
stuff from this in the process.
What?
Uh
All right, let's go check this PR real
quick.
If this is reasonable, I'll give it a
quick review now.
That's cool.
Yeah, I like that.
Oh, you just gave me binaries.
Should have the gen scripts, but it's
not bad.
Don't need to avoid the mess. Weird.
But, that's fine.
Oh, this is the dot C. Yeah, okay.
Where's the dot H?
Yeah, but it's not useful. That like
there's no reason to have it.
Gen scripts were in Python. I see. Yeah,
you can still stick them in if they're
in Python. It's better if they're in C,
but it's like it's still fine to just
stick a script in there for gen. I'd
rather you do that. Like I would keep
the like the binaries cuz they're small
so that you don't have to run them as
part of setup or something, but I would
like to have the level gen script if
it's available.
Okay, 595, I would see this is like a
mediumish sized den. This is not like
super trivial.
Yeah, so this should go in the dot C.
But yeah, this is some AI right there.
Uh
There's a bunch of like typical AI being
[ __ ] at programming things in here.
Do be honest on how much you like how
much AI is in here cuz I will review
code but like I'm not going to spend my
time pointing out like mistakes
um
that the AI has made if it's not
human-written
because the point of that would be for
you to learn and if it's not your
mistake
then like there's no point in me
spending my time doing that.
Like for instance this being a
completely stupid check here.
AI loves to do this type of crap.
And this stuff as well.
It's just like the [ __ ]
Everything else was you doing it? Okay,
then that's at least reasonable.
It's not about switching models badge.
It's like
it's about taking ownership of your own
code.
Why is everything life cycle? There's no
life cycles.
Like there's literally no memory
allocation that should be happening in
this loop at all. So the concept of a
life cycle is completely redundant.
This should never be
allocate on reset? Like why?
Like why isn't this a mem copy here,
right?
Unless I'm misreading this and this
isn't contiguous memory but it should be
contiguous memory.
Uh this can technically break if you're
relying on this getting carried. So
these are auto reset for you
in popper four. So if you're relying on
this state being preserved across steps,
it won't be.
But I see what you did here. This type
of thing is generally reasonable.
Okay, this one I can genuinely teach
you. So like this this should be an
early return.
Like you should have this check inverted
and then continue.
Cuz otherwise you get the Kamehameha of
just like indent indent indent indent.
So whenever you have a check like this
where there's no else on it
and you're like you can just invert the
check and then not keep indenting [ __ ]
like eight levels.
Same thing here.
Uh actually no, not same thing here but
same thing here.
Hey, you don't ever give it like a
negative 0.01
per move.
You don't you don't encourage it to like
you don't ever want to encourage it to
have short horizons via the reward like
this.
This is the job for the gamma parameter
in generalized advantage estimation. You
don't want to use like a constant like
this.
This plus 0.03 may or may not be
required.
This one definitely isn't.
Eh, this is clever.
I didn't actually know that you could do
that.
Yeah, this thing is actually clever. I
actually really like this trick.
Um
Okay, I'm going to have to look how you
did that. That doesn't make sense to me
that that works.
That's cool. That's very cool though.
Instead of having to write a shader.
Probably inefficient but it's the render
or whatever.
And not bad. I do have a feeling this
can probably be a bit tighter.
I'd say decent first end.
There are
some
just like
general programming things that you can
improve. And then there's some things
that are like
these are obviously AI stupid things,
but you should know better than to like
let this
be stuck in the code.
Um
Stuff like the mem copy is important for
performance to understand.
That reward error was the biggest thing
that I saw like conceptual thing on the
RL side.
How much code do I think I could If I
were to write this, how much code do I
think I could get out of this?
Just kind of guessing based on the feel
of this.
I'd probably say if I wrote this, it
would be about 100 lines shorter.
So, definitely some stuff you can
tighten up.
It's a nice end though.
And I will merge it.
But I'm going to request that you uh
you submit me a follow-up with some
improvements if you're interested in
this type of stuff.
And you'll learn a lot doing it.
I did kind of the same thing with Tim's
environment. Tim's first end. Tim's
first end had way more mistakes and
errors and things than this one does
actually. And he learned a lot by just
doing that refactor.
You can try the uh the 0.3 per new sync
as a shaping reward. That can bias your
final policy. And I wouldn't be
surprised if it's not required. But that
one is more up to uh experimentation.
Um the one that's not up to
experimentation is the negative 0.01.
Like that just shouldn't be there.
Also in the render, the line should draw
under the pufferfish.
Yeah.
I like that.
Like the lasers are allowed to cross,
right? Or are they not? Oh, they're not
allowed Wait.
Are they allowed to cross or not for the
final solution of it?
Nice first end PR though.
Any other questions for me or should I
get back to um
the
tutorial I was writing?
Any more questions for me before I get
back to the tutorial end?
I think thanks for the PR. I hope you're
learning stuff and uh
I look forward to having this in Puffer
with a full tune. Like if you get it
nicely cleaned up and it seems like it's
reasonably scalable for learning, we can
run a full sweep and get it onto
constellation.
Okay.
This is going to be sort of like
Groundhog Day in a sense, right?
In that we decide whether it's uh
an early spring and I get to start on
Puffer 4 soon cuz I'm mentally recovered
or Puffer 5 cuz I'm mentally recovered.
Not a good sign there.
Um
or whether it's six more
days of [ __ ] around playing Runescape
because my mind just doesn't work yet.
We'll see.
The good news is I actually don't really
have the desire to [ __ ] around playing
Runescape anymore.
Which means I've at least partially
recovered. But I also don't have the
drive back for my normal stuff either.
I've kind of just been enjoying like
walking around outside and listening to
my book.
>> Haven't seen a cool puff for 5 years
yet. Oh, I know it's very cool, man. I
like my work.
But, um I have to be actually able to
have some level of capacity
to do my work, you know?
Convert it to CUDA back end format.
Uh, that might be a little annoying to
do. I'll try.
That sounds good.
Tomorrow is Friday, I'll be streaming.
I'm on Eastern time, of course.
I'll be streaming.
Can do some inferno wing
if, um
You agree that having a multi-discrete
action space where one of those actions
can prevent any of the other actions
from doing anything is bad.
dependent effect to just that action.
Like I could very easily see that you
would want to have like an action space
where you can shoot or jump and one
overrides the other or something.
If you can merge them and it makes
sense, it's probably better, too. But I
could see situations where you might
have to do that.
I'm working on a new tutorial on
as well as a slide deck at the moment.
Probably I would have done different
stuff, Liberty. I don't know.
I think realistically I could have
probably done it in the same time frame,
but mentally it would have been a lot
harder
because what I would have had to have
done
instead of like learning along the way,
I would have had to have mentally
justified taking 2 weeks off from dev to
just like go study CUDA
and then come back and do it.
It might have been it probably would
have been a little bit more delayed, but
better.
And ultimately now I'm going to have to
go back and do that at some point
anyways.
I don't know, man.
using the models makes me feel deeply,
deeply irritated and unsettled.
Not because they're good, but because
they're really [ __ ] dumb and it's
like not a good way to be building stuff
that you intend to actually matter.
It's just so intellectually lazy and
anathema to me.
So it's tough cuz in some situations
like you just need to have a thing done
and you need to cut corners.
But it's like
it kind of feels like, yeah, we can just
get this done a lot faster if we just
disable all the safety features on the
machine and hope nothing happens.
Is this chest dress? I mean, uh,
Spencer.
Okay.
No idea that wouldn't be what you're
doing.
Um, hang on. Let me open this on the
side.
Like that's a strat that doesn't cause
some downsides, I guess.
I see Volts doing this Wordle thing in
the chat.
If anybody wants to do a really, really
stupid NLP environment
um that I just thought of,
one thing you could do would be to have
you could just give it like the alphabet
as the action space
and an enter option
and then it just gets uh plus
n reward for the length of the reward a
length of the word
if it is a valid English word and has
not been listed this episode, otherwise
fail and a reset.
And just see how many real words it
learns to type.
That'd be kind of funny.
It's infinitely scalable in a sense that
you can just keep typing words.
You can literally just have it keep
typing words.
That'd be kind of a fun end.
>> I don't know. I just proposed a silly
environment and um
that's what they were calling it.
Uh
that's super funny.
Why the [ __ ] does it do this? It just
like grabs random crap.
It's literally just grabbed my freaking
RuneScape client from my other monitor.
this just needs to exist.
And if I don't build it, it won't exist.
Like
the companies are all competing to do
the exact same thing.
I think it's very likely that they're
going to hit a dead end.
I think a lot of the knowledge in
reinforcement learning is being lost
um because they've drained all the
actually talented people doing it.
And many of the people that we have left
in the field are not the most talented.
And we essentially have a pretty short
window in which to
solidify everything and make this stuff
work or it's lost.
And uh we end up trying to throw 1
million times too large models at
everything and wondering why stuff is
expensive and fails.
>> their reasoning models. What does that
mean, dude?
Everybody keeps saying reasoning, and
nobody actually knows what the [ __ ]
they're talking about.
Yeah, but you can't just You can't just
take a word that means something thing,
and then define it to mean something
that has like absolutely no bearing on
that thing, right?
What would you call what they call
reasoning?
I don't know. Test time scaling is a
good one.
I'm just working on a simple tutorial
demo and right now. I'm trying to get
something that's like pretty
non-trivial, but also pretty compact.
The squared and target are
quite simple.
And um the code for target is also too
long.
I want something that's cooler than
target, but shorter.
You'll see when I finish it. It'll be
done fairly soon.
I don't know. There's a very weird
dynamic in research
where like
in 2019 or so, there was a lot of really
cool stuff happening at the uh big labs
in reinforcement learning.
And academia was mostly just being a
bunch of stubborn old crusty [ __ ] like
ignoring it. And um they did a bunch of
meaningless work as a result.
But then at some point, like it shifted
to the big labs actually just being the
hype machines that the academics thought
that they were the whole time.
And they stopped for the most part
producing usable research.
Um
and then they really started like
tipping everything more towards
marketing and scaling crap and not
actually
doing anything, at least in RL.
So.
It wasn't always the case. There were a
few years where OpenAI was like
genuinely awesome.
Um DeepMind, I think there probably are
still some teams that are genuinely
quite good there.
Way better now. Uni labs are such horse
[ __ ]
I was free to choose my project crit,
and there were some smart people. But I
had basically zero resources.
Like the clusters were unusable.
I pretty much like I ended up doing
everything on my own like my own desktop
and my own compute.
And I had very little of that even.
Like you would not believe how [ __ ]
[ __ ] some of the cluster stuff is at
these top universities. Like imagine 50
PhD students all spamming the crap out
of a shitty AF fast file system where
everything is mounted to the point that
it takes 30 seconds to start Python. You
have these hundred thousand dollar
nodes, right? And you can't even use
them because the file system is so dog
[ __ ]
Oh, and then also everybody is like
spamming and taking them all up anyway,
so go [ __ ] yourself.
Yeah, I took some of the NBA courses
while I was there cuz you don't get
charged for course and I had to take
some electives. I learned a lot from
those courses, but not because what they
were telling me, but because of
observing how stupid those people were.
Like Jesus Christ, I've never met a
bunch of dumber and more insufferable
people in my life.
Holy crap.
It gave me a lot of confidence actually
to just do my own thing because it's
like
well, these guys are worthless.
I don't need a business partner from
this. I need to do my own thing.
I'll go find some good technical people.
Job submission system.
Um
those also suck, Brett. Uh we didn't
have one of those and that is not the
solution.
Like the solution to this is so
incredibly easy.
You literally just buy some computer
like you buy some compute [ __ ] you can
buy some desktops and stick them in a
closet somewhere. It's that easy. And
then you give each each grad student
some SSH access to a few of those.
That's it.
It's that easy.
And you can argue well, that's really
not optimal, blah blah blah, but if that
stupid thing that I come up with is more
effective than what they have, then
they're failing.
So
if you're too dumb to do the complicated
thing correctly, then at least do the
simple the simple thing correctly.
I really wish we could compile this
chunk of the code with address
sanitizer, you know?
Mhm. This would be a lot nicer when we
fully get rid of Python the stack traces
will get much nicer.
Another motivation to do it.
I really do need to get us some better
debugging on this.
GPU programming are other suggestions.
Well, yeah, there's lots to do.
But it's just it's a little bit more
advanced, right?
Like we have our whole infrastructure
stack that can be cleaned up and made
faster.
Got like 5,000 lines of CUDA training
code.
I need to get better tools for that for
sure.
What's your favorite game in general?
Runescape.
Uh it depends a lot on the students and
the advisors.
Do a lot these days.
I mean, you literally see right behind
me. Look at all the machines, James,
right?
Runescape for real?
Yeah.
I mean, when I was super burnt out from
the release
I
got a couple 99s and then I was
playing leagues
the temp game mode.
This is the other account.
So actually, my side monitor right now
is two different accounts.
Second most favorite game?
Uh Dofus, different MMO.
That one I grew up playing.
It's like tactical fantasy chess on
steroids as an MMO.
>> I mean it literally is though. It's like
I don't know. Did you ever play any of
the old Fire Emblem games? I guess even
some of the more recent ones.
It's like grid-based tactical turn-based
like grid-based turn-based tactical
combat.
Yeah, it's like that is an MMO with
leveling and progression and spells and
equipment and builds and like
uh dungeons with very complicated
mechanics.
And like literally thousands of quests
that get you very rare items and [ __ ]
It's like nutty.
It's a very nutty game.
It's like this, right?
You know, grid-based thing. There's like
a tactical mode. And also there's like a
render overlay. You have like ranges and
areas of effect and [ __ ] and tons of
Yeah.
Apparently there's a 3.0 out.
Oh.
Huh. Apparently they launched a 3.0.
Apparently they removed the tactics
mode. That's nutty.
Yeah, but like you really don't put
anywhere near the same number of hours
into a single-player game
as you can into an MMO.
Like I've played tons of games.
I get a lot of my research ideas from
games, in fact.
But nothing really clicks with me uh
long-term like
a good MMO.
Uh
Dofus like way predates Clash of Clans,
so.
A really good game.
And they have a 3.0 mode. They have a
3.0 update with new graphics out lately.
It's pretty cool.
Unfortunately it has nowhere near the
popularity these days of um
of other things, so.
I hope it does stick around for much
longer though. It's a really really cool
and unique game.
Volt, I you're probably not going to
like this, but I um I listened to the
full Lord of the Rings series while I
was running
a summer or two back.
And
it really doesn't crack my list for like
uh
I really just didn't click with the
writing of it.
It's decorated writing, but it's not
decorative in the
the way that I tend to like.
Um
I found very little of it memorable.
I don't know. I'm reading the Stormlight
Archives now.
Okay, next.
What do you mean?
Listening to the full audiobooks, not
the [ __ ] movies.
Um remember like games in RL is not a
new thing.
Like there's a very long tradition of
using games in AI research.
And most of the professors who don't see
the value in that are kind of just the
crusty old ones that are out of touch.
Listens to books.
Volt, you're not going to win that one.
Like audiobooks are a thing.
Hm.
Do they not have those in Finland?
Like unless you go unless you're going
to tell me that you go running and you
have a book up in front of you like this
or you're benching and you have a
[ __ ] book tape to the bar.
All right, let's figure this [ __ ] out.
I'm stalling.
What else have I read recently? Full
Eragon series holds up tremendously
well.
Um
Heroes of the Calderon.
What else have I read lately that I
liked?
Those are the two that come to mind.
Sci-fi obviously Culture series.
My favorite.
I don't really like most sci-fi.
Uh yeah, I did read those, but the thing
is I read a lot of stuff when I was
younger.
Like I read a huge huge amount.
Um
I don't know if those would actually
hold up.
They probably wouldn't.
Just trolling?
Who, me or him?
I used to watch movies when I was
younger. I just don't enjoy them anymore
for whatever reason.
Blue dye.
Who [ __ ] movies?
No, I'm not. You can clown someone for
not having read Shakespeare, not for
like not having seen the [ __ ] Lord of
the Rings movies.
Oh, play this Republic.
I never really gotten into philosophy.
Every like little bit of intro
philosophy I took, I just found
profoundly stupid.
I mean, look, monks have great unarmed
damage, right?
Okay, this is a lot closer to what I
wanted.
There we go.
Nice poppers.
Benchmarks are interesting. You probably
can, Amber, but the thing is you
actually need to write the the
environments to be optimized.
Like you write your M's in high perf C
and then you're good.
Which the thing is most of the time it's
not even any harder to write the M's in
high perf C. It's just like people are
morons and default to the worst Python
you've ever imagined.
All right, some more work can be done
here. We need to make sure that this is
really cool.
Use the restroom real quick.
No more espresso. I've had enough
espresso today.
>> a decent problem for the representation,
isn't it?
It just instantly solves, no matter
what.
Look at the puffer.
Look how friendly he is.
Now, if I add two agents and six
targets,
500k, which is with pick phase.
Eh.
That's fun.
9,000 agents. Yeah, so we could do that.
The problem is the obs encoding.
I'm just trying to think what would be
the coolest demo that we could do with
this.
That one seems good. This is like about
the most that you can visually keep
track of.
We'll make it a one in 10 chance that it
changes.
They kind of are stealing stars from
each other. That's sort of the point.
Continuous learning?
What do you mean continuous learning?
You're watching me train them right here
in like a few seconds.
You can't just give up like a factor of
10,000 speed and expect things to still
work.
Like the simi- like they need the Having
to have a simulation is not a bug.
That's a feature.
Like
a lot of important problems can be
solved in sim.
And they can't just be solved from the
real world.
Okay, this is actually like nice. This
is what I wanted here.
Reset per epoch or is demo just post
trained?
Uh whenever you see me launch one of
these experiments, that's me training a
new model from scratch. So this one
takes 17 seconds. We could probably make
it quite a bit faster
to train.
We should easily be able to get this to
like 20 mil steps per second, so
well.
A billion steps.
A fluffy puffer.
That's funny.
Yeah, you should be able to train a
perfect policy in way less than a
billion steps for that end.
Good setup, right?
Uh, I mean, they can do that. They'll
still get it wrong.
It's honestly way cheaper for them to
just hire us to do stuff.
Seems very weird to me. How the heck is
this
Remember, the number of people that I've
seen that are supposed to have 20 years
of industry experience that make a mess
of our route is very high.
Like I've seen millions upon millions of
dollars squandered just due to
incompetence.
Like it's way easier to just chuck us a
few hundred thousand to do whatever the
hell it is that you want.
I don't see this bug. Does anybody see
the bug?
Oh, oh, oh.
It's just mostly um
lean meat, vegetables, some carbs like
I have a few supplements. I have a
protein shake in the morning.
I don't know what the [ __ ] I did. This
is going to be a stupid bug, I'm sure.
It's just a quick check to see if it
spots the bug. I'm not having it write
any code for this.
Oh, is it four plus?
Yes, that is. That's it.
All right, that's why it's not working.
Cool.
It's actually kind of bad if that's the
case.
Yeah, okay.
You kind of need to do something about
that.
Look at that. They're waiting.
That's cool.
All right, we'll fix a few small things
and then um
It's actually a lot easier to follow
with only three agents.
That looks way That is going to be cool,
I think.
>> Okay, I think I like this.
Let's just clean it up now.
Okay, this is like the really easy one,
right?
Yeah, this is kind of like the convert
environment.
I think that there's a better demo in
here somewhere.
Okay, so what if instead of putting the
thing on a cool down,
what if they just change the type of the
target?
Yeah, so that's going to happen. Okay,
so
I think they're still going going
exploit it, right?
Yeah, they're kind of all just going to
do this [ __ ] right?
That's not good.
Yeah, so they all just do one pattern
here, right?
And then they're going to do one pattern
here.
And then they're going to do a pattern
here, right?
But now if we crank this up to 60,
what happens?
No.
I was hoping this would work.
Um.
We'll keep the uh sample and simple
then.
This is not a problem I have to solve
right now.
I don't want to solve this stupid thing,
don't I?
I'm going to just clean this up and
shorten it a ton and I'll be good.
It's kind of a dumb action space, isn't
it?
Yeah, I think Carpathy has kind of
cooked himself.
I'm getting like
mega
SF acid vibes lately.
It's a real shame.
>> Oh, nice. That's actually slightly
better.
See if I can get this down to like 100
lines.
How's Puffer 4 dev going?
Puffer 4 has been out for a few weeks,
my friend.
And uh it is much, much better than I
anticipated when I started working on
it.
It took a huge amount of work.
I basically am just now starting to get
back to work properly. I fried myself so
badly
getting it out.
But it's pretty awesome.
I'm working on um a new tutorial and for
it today.
Among other things.
I mean, this one was really a huge
amount of work.
I
That's the worst burnout I've had in
probably since I started Puffer.
That was nutty, nutty.
>> I don't like this, you know, this like
four whatever loop. I like it more like
this.
Dr. Mario.
Anish, I asked if you were here a long
time ago. I was like, yeah, I'll do your
thing. And then you just kind of like
[ __ ] off.
And now you've got me in the middle of
finishing this thing before dinner.
I want to eat dinner.
That was a long dinner, my guy.
I could do a night stream.
I have dinner in about an hour, but I
eat quick.
I could do it after that.
I wouldn't mind doing that actually.
That'd be fine.
I also shouldn't golf this to the point
that I wouldn't want to I wouldn't want
this code in my
standard library, right?
Okay, we'll think about that, but let me
just go through and just all the stuff
that's random and
crappy.
Wish I could get a perfect metric for
this.
Hello, Robin. Hey, Spencer.
It is I.
Uh, I guess I can take a break from this
to do the Dr. Mario thing before dinner
and then I can finish this after.
Um, I've been working on a new tutorial
env for us, Spencer.
I wanted to be 100 lines. It's probably
going to be 125 or 150.
And it's actually going to help us in
some research as well.
Messed around and saw some improvements.
If you have a PR up, I'll look at it.
I can do that now.
Mhm.
When should I review?
It's improving, but slow.
Yeah, fair enough.
Try playing it.
Uh, if I'm going to review, I'll review.
If not, I'm going to finish this thing.
I'd like to have this env implemented.
Yeah, Spencer, I think that this env is
going to help us both for like
multi-agent stuff, but also for um
like encoder stuff. It's going to be a
nice and useful.
It's kind of a refinement of um
the convert env from before.
Um, so that's going to be the subject of
some stuff, Spencer. I have a few ideas
for things. Like I'm wondering what
happens if we just randomize the point
order
and stuff like that.
I have some ideas.
I want to get this to be just like a
really clean minimal env first, though.
Because it looks pretty cool if you
watch it, like
it's like the behavior is not quite
there yet.
But like it's going to be a much more
interesting env than the current target
is.
Okay, this one's not trained nicely.
Um, it's a sort of a multi-agent
coordination env in the sense that you
have to get the star that matches your
color and then you change color, but
then that star goes on cool down for a
couple seconds.
So, it's tough cuz you have to learn to
like split up and stuff.
So,
we'll play with it.
Yeah, I need to just make it a little
shorter.
Hi Spencer.
I'm almost done cleaning this up. I'm
going to probably put in a little bit
more time on this tonight. I just want
to get us like a nice
you know, close as I can to 100 line
non-trivial env. I think we'll be able
to use it for the encoder stuff. So I
like kill two birds with one stone. Um,
I made these slides today
for some talks.
Where is it?
Yeah, I made these slides today for some
talks.
And um, I think it'd be nice to have
just like
single or two pane screenshot with a
whole env on it.
It's also just like you don't exactly
fully know what you're doing with those
rewards.
Right? Like you can be biasing the
optimal policy quite substantially.
Also like the negative constant reward,
that's what gamma does. You don't need
to bias your reward function to do that.
Like you already have a hyper parameter
that does that.
Yeah, that's pretty [ __ ] dumb. Don't
do that.
It's just annoying for the screenshots,
right?
I actually would prefer white space for
um C to be honest, just because of stuff
like this.
>> Yeah, this is the chunk I think that
needs the most clean up.
Off release. We already released Popper
4, my guy.
3 weeks ago.
Yeah, we have tons of articles. We got
demos.
We got um
constellation literally runs in your
browser.
Biggest data set of our L experiments
right here.
That was a hell of a release.
I've basically been gone for most of 2
weeks.
I think what I know it will do with this
actually.
I know what we'll do.
I'm going to have to do a little bit of
this after dinner. I might decide to
stream it. We will see.
Have to leave in a few.
Um I'll keep on this for a couple
minutes, but for folks who've been
watching,
make sure you star Popper on GitHub. It
really does help us out a lot and it's
free.
It gets Popper in front of the eyes of
more uh industry clients, so I can spend
more time on research
and less time on advertising.
All right, see y'all. Like I'll be back
tomorrow.